I know this is serious you got an odd
way of showing it just that anytime that
I'm afraid I make jokes knew you were
lightweight well she still doing the
helium
maybe you trying to burp yourself down
like Charlie Bucket super way around
where is she
[Applause]
/ all new episodes return Tuesday April
10th on the CW number one question I got
for you miss Candace is all centered
around this mystery girl let's take a
look at this girl right here girl isn't
she gorgeous
I never before on her show yeah just a
few times yeah she keeps popping up
mm-hmm yeah who is that Candace I don't
know she was a caterer at our wedding
jitters a couple times
yeah I don't know who she is but she
looks darling she looks familiar
she does look familiar Candace yes she
does you know who she looks like I will
say she looks like you came that's crazy
yeah how could that even be possible I
don't know maybe because it's dawn Allan
Barry and irises future daughter who has
come back to the past I have no comment
on that I don't know anything about that
what would you say to the fans out there
who have that theory right now there are
so many theories actually out there
online that I've seen and all of them
I'm like that's super cool I wonder if
we're doing that but I genuinely have no
idea in the script like that character
doesn't even have like a name so I don't
know I'm very excited to see as soon as
I saw her in the crossover episode oh
really
as soon as I saw her I was like she's
someone special mmm and then I texted
Danielle I said that's got to be their
daughter everybody it's charlie whole
bunch of flash stuff to break down so if
you're finding me for the first time be
sure to subscribe to get all the DC
videos there's a new round of the flash
ring giveaway too and I'll explain the
schedule because the flash is going on
break til April 10th I put that Candice
Patton clip at the beginning because she
directly addresses all of those coffee
shop girl theories I think it's
important the way she reacts to that
when I do believe that she has
absolutely no idea what the producers
intend to do with that character because
the last season she said that they did
not tell her whether or not she was
going to die at the end of the season
for real like perma death so if they
didn't tell her something really big
like that they probably haven't told her
anything about coffee shop girl
although the interviewer there also
implies she's friends with Danielle
panabaker
and Danielle said that she wasn't gonna
say anything about coffee shop girl but
the thing about Danielle is that she did
a video a while ago that I posted in one
of my breakdowns and she said that she
had no idea who the tornado twins were
so if this person really is Don Alan and
it's their child then DP probably
doesn't have any idea either it usually
sounds like when there's a big twist
coming down the road the only people on
the cast that actually have an idea for
what's going on or Grant Gustin himself
in the producers and that's about it for
those of you that are backing the theory
that this is Don Alan Berry and irises
daughter the sarcastic way the Candice
Patton reacts to the actress being the
exact same age as her just lends a
little more credence to that but like I
said she hundred percent does not know
who that person is there's no name for
her in the script and I explained in my
episode 16 video why she might not like
Harrison wells and killer frost but she
does like Barry Cisco an elongated man
so just keep that in the back of your
mind like if they seem like they're
stacking more evidence in line to her
being related to Barry and iris like you
know she looks an awful lot like you
Candice yeah you know she does look kind
of like me she looks darling she looks
familiar
she does look familiar Candice yes she
does you know who she looks like I will
say she looks like you that's crazy but
the big thing with next week's episode
like they make the Willy Wonka joke
maybe you should just burp like Charlie
Bucket the meta is a helium based meta
her name is Janet petty she's not a
comic book character but the other bus
meta that Harrison Wells mentions at the
end of last week's episode is Edwin
Gauss and he has a really important
ability I don't know if he's going to
appear during episode 17 but we know
that he's the last bus meta on that list
of 12 in the comics his name is the
folded man his ability is literally
folding into other dimensions like you
know the thinker uses technology to fold
into that pocket dimension
check this out space the final frontier
now you see it now you don't that's
exactly what it looks like when the boat
disappears that is the warping signature
of someone moving into pocket dimension
does someone want to explain what that
means
Einstein postulated that it was
theoretically possible for a region
specific fold in this space-time to
exist between the four dimensions that
we typically think of yeah that doesn't
help it's it's another dimension one
that you can enter or exit at any
location when Gauss as a bus Mehta
should be able to do that naturally so
that's a really important ability to
have the thinker would be able to
teleport around at will so it's a really
huge ability but he debuted during the
Walter West era of the Wally West comics
so Wally had gone away and when he came
back he came back as Walter West an
alternate future timeline version of
Wally West where Linda Park had died so
it's a bit of a reference to the
sabotage season remember the future
version of Barry after iris had died he
went all emo imagine that version of the
flash came back and was the main version
of the flash for a couple weeks until
the real version of Barry came back that
was kind of what happened with the
Walter West era like he was a hardcore
version of Wally because Linda had died
and it just made him open up on all of
the flash rogues that he went up against
so folded man was one of those people
but in the comics folded man used a
special suit to fold dimensions he could
become two-dimensional and just like
wrap around people like elongated man
does or his super saiyan mode was
becoming four-dimensional so that he
could fold three dimensions into other
places so I'm just expecting the TV show
to do a slightly simpler version of that
like imagine the visual effect when the
thinker reports in and out of places
that's probably what the folded man's
power will look like on a TV show but
the other really big thing about the
next episode in addition to not being
till April 10th I know there's a break I
think the production just needs some
more time to finish episodes is that
it's gonna be Kevin Smith's episode he
posted a whole bunch of behind the
scenes pictures so it made a little more
sense when I saw the breacher in gypsy
were listed on the IMDB because he was
posting pictures with Danny Trejo like
hey
Cisco's best friend is back who knows
why so it might be a subplot that's
separate from what's going on with the
main team flash mission to track down
these bus metas I'm going to hunt you
but here's just a little clip of Kevin
Smith talking about his episode because
he and Jason Mewes will guest star in it
and do their Jay and Silent Bob thing
for like a really brief scene so this
time around there's a scene that had two
security guards in it and so the writers
of the episode Kristin and Lauren
Kristin Kim asked me specifically she
goes we were wondering like do you think
you and Jay would want to play the
security guards so we shot a scene Jason
and I will replay two security guards in
the flash and it's it's it's not Jay and
Silent Bob
but Jason speaks and I don't so there
you go so just a reminder next episode
of the flash is until April 10th I'll do
bonus videos during the break no worries
leave all your requests in the comments
below
but there is a new episode of legends of
tomorrow next week Jesse quick is
crossing over and Constantine it's gonna
be all about the death totem so we'll do
a video for that on Monday night but
after that I don't think that Jesse
quick is gonna come back because she was
just cast on another TV show and they've
started working on that so if she comes
back after next week it's probably not
gonna be till season 5 the other really
cool things that just happened is that
god speed just came back in the comics
so let me know if you want me to do a
new god speed video for the comic book
arc that's going on right now because
we're getting ready for flash war and
Action Comics is getting ready to drop
its 1000th issue pretty soon too but
there was a whole bunch of other comic
book news that just dropped between
Marvel and DC so I'll try to get through
all that stuff as fast as possible I'll
post updates in that top pin comment and
on Twitter for the video schedule so
just check that out and congratulations
to the latest giveaway winner at querque
please private message me on the about
page of my youtube channel so I can get
your contact info but click here for
that new flash episode 16 video and
click here for brand new infinity war
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
you